[Music]
the 2021 state of devops report released
last year
it contained findings about how teams
navigate key areas of software delivery
we talked with two of the researchers
dustin smith and dave stanky about the
reports section on security
hi dustin and dave were there any
surprising findings in this section of
the report you would think that the more
steps i add into my process the slower
it will be but i think it's really about
how teams are integrating these
practices and are they doing it by
looking at their entire system and
figuring out how they can best fit them
into the actual process so that it is
seamless and that should be the idea
with any of these practices
and we find that teams that implement
these practices are actually delivering
software faster and more reliability and
all while seeing value driven to the
business so one thing that we found
consistently and yet i'm still surprised
by it every time is that we don't have
to make a compromise or a trade-off
between delivering fast and delivering
well we found that teams that have the
best secure code practices actually are
the same ones that are delivering the
most frequently and the having the
shortest lead time from code to delivery
so we really can have both fast and and
and
market responsiveness and security and
reliability
what exactly did the security section of
the report focus on
i think one of the important things to
clarify
with how we looked at security is that
we weren't looking at things like how
many vulnerabilities did you experience
in the last year we weren't measuring
how secure is your team
instead what we focused on were what
practices have you implemented on your
team in order to detect and recover from
security vulnerabilities
in
an effective way
that's one of the key differences that
we try to focus on
for several reasons
one of the main ones is that
people may not be willing to share how
many vulnerabilities they've experienced
but they are willing to share what
practices they've built into their
process
what did you find separated elite teams
from the rest
the real fundamental thing that we see
is they do something called shifting
left on security the teams that are
succeeding are the ones that are
bringing security principles knowledge
and practices leftward into their
testing into their initial development
processes and making it something that
is uh known and and practiced throughout
the organization
they make a lot of use of automated
testing to to make it so that known
vulnerabilities can rapidly be detected
and and kicked back for remediation
and something that really high
performing teams like to do is having
guardrails or or pre-approved libraries
things that developers can pull into
their code with the assurance that those
have been vetted by experts and that
they're going to be
going to pass their security tests
because they've already been
built in the security practices have
already been built in elite performing
teams are more likely to build security
into their entire development process
and so that means not throwing over your
most recent change to the security team
and asking for approval right before
deployment and hoping that they do it
quickly it means pulling them
in earlier right at the designed dock
phase are you including your security
team
and then are you including security
reviews throughout your entire process
as well
and then do you have tests that check
for known vulnerabilities built into
your build process
and finally do you have pre-approved
libraries that you can pull into your
project and know that those
versions of those dependencies are
pre-approved and
secure
and ready to be used
how can teams start implementing these
practices
let's say go to the report
and look at all the practices that we've
outlined and try to identify some of
those quick wins that you can get
where's the where are the low-hanging
fruit and one of the nice things about
the report is that we also include
industry benchmarks for each practice so
you can get a rough idea of to what
degree has this practice already been
adopted in the industry
that should give you an idea even if you
haven't met with your team yet of where
potentially are we lacking
what would you say is the core idea from
this section of the report
really the meme is security is
everybody's job
um but that doesn't mean that it's not
your job it's uh it can be an
unfortunate interpretation that says
well if it's everybody's job then then
i'm covered i don't need to worry about
it right
well the the bad news is yeah it's your
job too and we find that teams that
succeed are the ones where everyone in
the organization really
internalizes the importance of shipping
secure code
now that doesn't mean that we expect
every person in an organization to be a
security expert and
a worldwide leader in in in software
security instead what we like to see is
a consultative model where an
organization has a team of real security
experts who are creating guidelines
creating uh pre-approved pipelines and
generally educating the organization
about how to incorporate security into
their work and then everyone throughout
the organization from design to
implementation to testing to operations
all can reflect that knowledge back into
the work so that it's re so that it's
incorporated in their day-to-day jobs i
think the over
arching principle should be that
we need to move from being reactive to
detective vulnerabilities and more
proactive and even diagnostic and just
noting that vulnerabilities are
essentially inevitable and so we need to
be able to come up with practices and
processes in order to recover from them
when they are detected in a way that is
quick
and scalable
where can users go to learn more
we've got a great resource on our google
cloud site that incorporates this year's
state of devops report as well as
previous years it's got a capability
catalog that shows all those
capabilities i mentioned and for each
one there's an article that talks about
what it is how to measure it and how to
get started practicing it
there's all that and more including a
self-assessment tool that i really
recommend you can check it all out at g
dot co
devops
[Music]
you